you
Google Facebook Apple Microsoft are all
moving ahead and I had a great speed in
improving this artificial intelligence
software so it's very exciting software
is gonna solve that where it'll look at
all the new information and present to
you knowing about your interests what
would be most valuable so making us more
efficient we're focusing our what we've
talked about on autonomous systems and
we sort of see it as the mother of all
AI projects so autonomy is something
that's incredibly exciting for us we'll
see where it takes us wouldn't it be
wonderful if some day we got to the
point where there were robots every
place they were running farms they were
running Apple they were running
berkshire hathaway and all you had to do
was one person could punch a button at
the start of every morning and all the
goods and services that we're getting
now would be turned out by robot it is
seeping into our lives in all sorts of
ways that we just don't notice we're
just getting better and better at it and
we're seeing that happen
in every aspect of our lives from
medicine to transportation to how
electricity is distributed and it
promises to create a vastly more
productive and efficient economy and if
properly harnessed can generate
you know enormous prosperity for people
opportunity for people can cure diseases
that we haven't seen before can make us
safer because it eliminates inherent
human error and a lot of work
our intelligence is going to be
extremely helpful and and the risk that
it gets super smart that's way out in
the future and probably we're talking
about but now what we're seeing is that
for the first time computers can see as
well as humans that's pretty incredible
and it's a third study on on Tesla's
autopilot version one which is
relatively primitive and found that it
was a forty five percent reduction in
highway accidents and that's despite
what a pilot one day just version one
version two I think will be least two or
three times better that's the current
version that's running right now so the
greater improvement is really dramatic
and we have to figure out some way to
ensure that the advent of digital super
intelligence is one which is symbiotic
with humanity
ai is probably the most important thing
in humanities that has ever worked on
now I think of it as something more
profound than electricity or fire and
anytime you work with technology you
need to learn to harness the benefits
and while minimizing the downsides you
know stepping back when you think about
you know a lot of problems in the world
today it's because we typically have a
constraint on resources AI for the first
time I think over time offers a
different construct things which are
constrained and look like a zero-sum
game today may not be so in the future
take education for example it's really
difficult to educate people in a
cost-effective way
AI we fundamentally change that equation
it may make it possible for us to have
clean cheap renewable energy for the
future so I think a lot of things will
play out in more positive ways than
people think I think probably by
internet your self-driving will be will
encompass essentially all modes driving
and be at least a hundred to two hundred
percent safer than a person by the end
of next year I'm talking maybe eighteen
months from them the idea that there's
gonna be a general AI Overlord that
subjugates us or kills us all I think is
not something to worry about I think
that is over height first of all we
don't know we're nowhere close to
knowing how to build the general AI
something that could set its own
objectives the second of all I think
it's unlikely that such a things first
instincts would be to exterminate us so
I'm optimistic about that one and
certainly don't think we need to worry
about it today
you